mosey nation what is going on in this
video
what i want to talk to you about is a
hot take that i had on people who
complain that their business is not
growing enough and yet
see everything as though people owe them
something and so i uh did two videos or
three videos a week for three years
and you know everyone you know you have
some bombs you have some great videos
and this is the among the top one
percent of videos that i made in terms
of the number of people who shared it
liked it commented all that stuff and it
was in a private community and i want to
make it public to you guys and so uh
this video uh truly will show you the
frame of mind and the perspective from
which to see customer success increasing
lifetime value how to ultimately provide
more value than everyone else does from
a framing perspective and it applies to
sex it applies to business and it
applies to life and this is one of the
hottest take videos you see if i share
any numbers in the video it's because it
was in the past we currently do 85
million a year and i have nothing to
sell you but then i may have had i don't
know what numbers i share but that was
in the past and that's why if you see a
discrepancy that's the difference so
anyways mosey nation there's a lot of
people broke i don't should be one of
them that's why i make these videos keep
being awesome i'll see you guys enjoy
what's up everybody happy saturday ah
man i've got a good one for you today i
um this is even one where i looked at
layla and i was like i'm gonna have to
take a walk on this one um
this kind of came to me and i was
thinking about it and it's just like
man it's it's it's this one kind of
philosophy so we have we have five five
core tenants at gym launch rather than
go through all of them i'll tell you
what one of them is and it's uh own it
that's
one of the five core tenants that we
have and if you are curious about what
why you would have those you make core
tenants so that you can always reference
them back for yourself
and for the employees that you have so
you can say like this is how we make
decisions right and you can always look
back at that and be like this is who we
are right so own it is one of them and
oh man this is so good a lot of people
get really upset about their customers
who sign for a 12-month membership and
then quit after three months right and
i'll hear the same people trying to get
out of franchise agreements that are
five years long right and saying this is
bs i haven't gotten the value
they didn't give me what they promised
they would give me right i'm being real
talk and so
one of the things and one of the ways
that we've
so we have
honest ridiculously ridiculously like
almost zero
churn on our highest level group so our
most expensive group we basically zero
turn and if you were to tell like if you
were to ask anyone
um or someone asked us like how are you
growing this that how are you going this
fast all this stuff is that honestly
i think it's just because i'm incredibly
insecure deep down and i have this huge
fear of rejection so i don't want anyone
to not like me and i don't want anyone
to feel like i'm not giving them um what
i what i said i was going to give them
and it's like it's a serious fear of
mine probably rooted in security if you
can shift your perspective from thinking
from well i just got the contract we're
done to like we just got the contract oh
[ __ ]
now we have to fulfill on this right the
way i see my relationship with the gym
lords group
i see it as a week to week like you guys
are on week to week with me unless i
perform unless i provide value like
everyone's gonna leave right now
obviously you need to be discerning you
need to be wise you need to protect
yourself with a contract that goes
without saying obviously right and you
have agreements that are there but if
you ever rely on your business because
of contracts you will lose always
because at the end of the day people
will do what they want to do if you rely
on contracts your life will be living
hell because then people are like well f
you like you trick me and all like
if you live on contracts
your life is going to be about contracts
and how about you i don't want my life
to be about contracts right you can go
even deeper with this okay so when like
i married layla i honestly had this
feeling we both had a conversation like
literally the day like the night of our
marriage and i was like
i was like [ __ ] i was like we can't mess
this up i was like this is it i was like
you're the one i committed to if
anything i was like i was like i like i
just don't it's like if we ever have
issues i was like we gotta confront
immediately because we're in this right
if you treat your marriage
right you've got that contract you're
like i got a contract you gotta be with
me right and you treat your marriage
like you treat your customers i got a
contract you have to stay here you have
to pay me you will lose and if life will
suck but if you consider it as week to
week like i consider us day to day and i
used to make that joke when we were
dating people like are you guys
committed like in a relationship this is
right before your married i was like
we're month to month
she hated it but the joke for me served
the fact that like you're only as good
as your last paycheck right you're only
as good as your last day and the moment
you rest on your laurels the moment you
get lazy is the moment someone else
who's hungrier will take you right and
that could be someone who's hungry who
takes your wife now obviously we have
commitments we have shared principles
that we never wanted like we believe in
i don't get biblical on you but like
like we believe when you get married you
stay married right that's like that's
the goal in that you can always make it
work with anyone right that's our belief
that was one of the things that we
checked on each other before we got
married right
but that being said if you look at what
the bible says right and this is just
marriage but the marriage and business
are so similar because you have to do
the stuff sometimes you don't want to do
and you got to be consistent you got to
do it every day you can't just say hey
great job this week and then not say
anything for two months to your
customers right same thing with the
marriage i can't just be like hey babe
thanks for making dinner once a month
and she makes dinner every single day
right and she crushes it she's awesome
layla's a freak she's amazing if i could
run our business away well she kind of
runs her business but the point is if
you're
losing customers and you're like all
these people are flaky no one commit no
one like and you want to get into victim
mindset of like lamenting
customers right
they're people and people will always be
self-serving you can always count on it
i had a mentor telling me that he's like
if you always predict that people will
act in their own self-interest he's like
you'll always be right and i've always
thought about that i was like wow he's
like you want to predict the future
protect them predict that they will act
in their own self-interest forget what
they say about principles forget what
they say about anything and so what you
want to do if you like which is why you
should always align relationships so
that how their best interest is with you
right so like i have to make legacy so
freaking good that their best interest
is staying and paying me right i'm being
super real with you and so if your
customers right at your gym keep leaving
and you keep saying no one's like no one
honors their word anymore no one does
any like
bs man like you probably didn't honor
your word
right because you're no longer in their
best interest anymore and they tell you
that by leaving right by having high
churn rates that's how they tell you
that that's how the market tells you
that you're not being good enough right
and so despite you despite signing the
12-month contract about signing the
18-month contract whatever it is
live week to week
live workout to workout because the real
contract that they have with you is for
today and the moment that one of your
employees gives them lip or says
something or says something rude or
doesn't show up on time or the bathroom
looks like [ __ ] or the music is the same
playlist they've heard every single time
they go to your gym they're gonna leave
that's it they'll come up with their
reason they'll say they got busy they'll
you know like
work or they're moving they'll come up
their friend's a doctor or a nurse
they'll get the fake note it doesn't
matter if someone wants to leave the
relationship to leave if your wife wants
to cheat on you she'll find a way so you
don't want that
so it's like i got to make this so good
that you don't want to look anywhere
else you think you'd be crazy to look
anywhere else right and they've like i
want i want my wife to go out and like
someone's like if some guy's like hey
like you know come on she's like do you
know what i have at home like like
you're a fool you i mean if you think
that that's gonna get me right like your
game is so low you have no idea what i
have right so they see a gym
advertisement for something else
they're like you have no idea my gym
like you have no idea how my trainers
treat me you have no idea how i feel
when i walk into that gym every day
right
how those people can make me feel
and so if you think about your
relationship with your customers as
you're only as good as yesterday you're
only as good as today that's it that's
all you've got and so every time you
have to resell them
like i sell layla every single day on
being with me
every single day because i love her to
death and i want i want this to be
awesome forever i do and i know that
i know that in order for that to happen
i can't just appreciate her once a week
i can't even appreciate her once a day i
tell her every like every moment baby i
love you i'm like you're awesome you're
so good i was like you managed our team
so well i could never do this without
you and it's true
right
and so
if you look oh here's another one ready
for it you've got your employees
everybody's got their employees
everybody complains about their
employees my employees don't work hard
enough they don't care about my
customers they don't care well how are
you showing up as a leader
how invested are you in them do they
feel
like my trainer left with all my
customers they left with that they left
with because it was so bad with you that
they had to look somewhere else it was
so bad that they had to leave
and so it's like how
how can i make this exchange fair
exchange how can i make this exchange
even abundant exchange as in they get
more than what they get from i i give
more than i get right how can i make
this an unfair advantage that's how you
have a value discrepancy value
discrepancies keep people people are
like people don't go to chipotle
because it's worth seven dollars people
go to chipotle because they pay seven
and they get a 20 meal that's why they
go to chipotle that's the secret i'm all
about raising prices but i'm all about
being 10 times more valuable than my
price which is three times more
expensive than everyone else and never
ever ever ever ever
taking it for granted i don't take your
attention for granted i don't take the
fact that you pay us every week for
granted because i know that there's
always somebody who's going to come
after me
and try and be better than us and i have
crazy insecurity um in thinking that
like tomorrow it could all be over
and i never want that to happen
and so um if you think about that
with your customers you will always be
ahead of your competition
like we're constantly innovating because
i'm like [ __ ] everyone's gonna copy my
stuff everyone's gonna copy the stuff i
came up with last month i gotta make new
stuff i gotta make new stuff right and
when you're when i'm concentrating on my
customers and not my competition right
then i make good [ __ ] right because i
want them to stay and i'm thinking
i'm only as good as my last paycheck
right i'm only i can only provide for
layla if i provide for you stuff that
makes you money for real
anyways so
this was a walk and talker i thought i
would uh just give you a little little
saturday morning love
as i get some fresh air in socal enjoy
soak in some of the socal weather but i
love you guys so if you guys don't have
amazing marriage amazing business
amazing relationship with your customers
amazing relationship with your employees
don't ever think about what you've done
because they don't people don't humans
don't right we don't remember what we
did we don't remember all those things
like every time i can't tell you how
many times my wife is taking the trash
out i always remember when i take it out
right we always remember what we do
but we forget what everyone else does
and we forget that they forget what we
did and we think that it's wrong that
they forgot
when in fact we just have to do more
again today
right because you can't change anything
else and i can't change how they're
going to think and so you can either
lament how human beings are
or you can react and win
and just adjust right you can just
adjust
so all you got to do is just know that
everyone's gonna forget no one will
honor their vows and if you think about
life that way
you will never be surprised in business
if people leave you then take it as a
sign i'm doing something wrong right if
there's some you know discontent in the
marriage take it as a science and be
like she doesn't appreciate me think
about how i can appreciate her more
right how can i make things better for
her so that she wants to stay right so
she gets excited
she like she doesn't want like she has
no energy anymore like okay cool why
don't we have energy why don't i make
her dinner once you know what i mean
or what like whatever whatever that
person's love language is i'm not get
too deep in like on the marriage side
but like
you got to fill their needs
customers
and employees too like especially
especially since we're selling service
most of us are selling service and if
you're selling service
you need to fulfill the person's needs
otherwise they're not going to fulfill
the needs of your customers right are
you investing in them do you want them
to grow are you giving them the things
that they need to move on and become
rock stars so anyways i love you guys i
hope you guys having an amazing amazing
day and weekend hope you found this
valuable as always thank you very much
for your attention i know that you have
many things to spend your attention and
eyeballs on and i'm honored that you
decided to spend the last few minutes
with me
on saturday morning lots of love guys if
you're a gym owner
and you haven't joined i promise we can
help make you a bunch of money and make
this business a lot easier for you so
lots of love guys talk to you soon